first add 250 milliliters of cream to a
pan then pour in 50 mils of milk and add
50 grams of caster sugar get the sugar
in earlier cause it stops the milk and
cream from boiling over give that a
little stir
bring out the ball panna cotta
which means cook cream in Italian can be
flavoured with anything from vanilla to
coffee to chocolate I'm giving mine a
grown-up kick with a splash of rum in
once the cream has come to the ball take
it off the heat and add a cup of leaves
our gelatine that will be soaked in cold
water and squeeze dry then whisk them in
and the gelatine sets the cooked cream
so on that really nice sort of LeMans
texture rich silky and incredibly smooth
once the gelatin has dissolved pour the
panna cotta straight into servant
glasses traditionally it's set in moulds
then turned out onto a plate
but I'm keep in mind simple leave a
little space on top for the glaze now
set them into the fridge beautiful
next the pomegranate glaze add some
castor sugar to the pan and pour in
pomegranate juice then simply bring it
to the boil and reduce it down to the
consistency of a sticky syrup
in Iran where pomegranates originated
they use this sweet sticky syrup to
flavour chicken and game birds a
beautiful rich sticky glaze pull that
into a jar leave that to cool down take
the panna cotta from the fridge
they set dutifully and they're not too
firm just slightly bouncing little it's
springy on top carefully pour the cooled
pomegranate glaze over just roll around
a little bit just to fill those edges
finally take a bar of chocolate that's
been chilled in the freezer so it's
easier to use and scrape off thin shards
almost like sort of chocolate gold leaf
and sprinkle it on top
you
muhr gays are traditional north african
sausages made from beef or lamb and all
going to do now
they say the sausage and lay that in the
middle they're flavored with harissa a
fiery chili paste which gives them the
heat and distinctive color and now you
can see the nuts absorbing all that
wonderful flavor some delicious
finally put in a sprig of rosemary